all right let's start with this real
quick because this is too good and I
have to play it for you right away I
just I can't wait Chicago police well
they're they're going to spend the next
year probably embarrassing Jessie
similar with releases and leaks and
information about the case and it will
be and has been a well-deserved public
shaming this one is is pretty good they
released the body cam footage from when
they first came to some a--let's house
and they have footage of him still with
the rope around his neck and it's it's
even more absurd than you imagined that
it would be because remember that after
Smollett paid the two dudes to jump him
he you need then they put the rope
around his neck he kept the rope on like
it was a necklace and just went home and
waited for the cops to arrive with the
with the rope still on so here's
Smollett with the rope
[Applause]
so that's that's something else and
that's a one thing you notice about that
rope is that it's a glistening white
brand-new rope this wasn't you know you
imagine a couple of racist rednecks if
they were attacking people with a rope
they would grab some old dirty rope from
the shed or something this is a this is
a rope that obviously someone just
picked up from the hardware store
like you know a half-hour before which
is exactly what happened but anyway I
tell you that now here's the interesting
thing about that video that video proves
conclusively that it was a hoax now we
we already knew that it was a hoax
obviously but if you didn't know if
there's any doubt in your mind well you
could put that doubt to rest because
there is no way that two racist dudes
would attack a guy who's wearing a
sweater like that did you see that
sweater there's just because the racist
dudes would assume that a guy wearing
that sweater has to be white even if he
doesn't look white I mean there's
there's got to be a white guy there's no
way a non-white guy would wear a sweater
like that now I personally and I'm not
making fun of the sweater I like the
sweater personally but case in point
right I'm more otherwise it white ass
dude you'll ever meet and I very white
tasty I mean I love corny ugly sweaters
so that's just the whitest sweater I've
ever seen and I'm thinking that as soon
as cops laid eyes on that sweater
they said this is fake no way no way you
wear a sweater like that you're not
getting attacked by racists just not
happening all right now a lot to talk
about including Bernie's
Anders just unveiled his plan to give
free college to everyone and to and to
erase student debt free college I mean
this guy is Santa Claus just giving out
free stuff to everyone we'll talk about
that in a minute but first a quick word
from Jen you sell do you wish that you
know the double chin and all that would
would would just disappear well
newsflash
ladies and gentlemen people look at your
jawline and it tells your age like the
like the rings of a tree it gives away
your age here's Robin from Lubbock Texas
I put Jen you sell jawline cream on my
neck two or three days ago this is the
best my neck has looked in 20 years
people told me my face looks young I'm
blown away
using MDL technology and Chamonix is
propriety base Jenny sells brand-new jaw
line treatment specifically targets the
delicate skin around the neck and jaw
for tight healthy younger looking skin
you can see results right before your
eyes or you get a hundred percent of
your money back no questions asked
either like it it works so you get your
money back but I don't think you're
gonna want your money back because this
thing's gonna work order now and the
classic Gen you sell four bags and
puffiness is free with your order and it
starts seeing results in 12 hours or
less Jen you sell immediate effects is
also yours free so you're getting a ton
of stuff no double chin no turkey neck
no sagging jawline because no one needs
to know your age go to Gen you sell calm
that's Jan you sell calm n term at 25 at
checkout get your two free gifts free
Express chip shipping go to Gen you sell
calm in term at 25 at check check out
that's gen you sell dot-com all right
so yesterday Bernie Sanders unveiled a
plan to cancel all student debt cancel
just get rid of it like it never
happened
magical just like that here's from CNN
it says the new legislation would cancel
1.6 trillion dollars of student loan
undergraduate and graduate debt for
approximately 45 million people his
ambitious plan that's one way of putting
it has no eligibility limitation
limitations and will be paid for with a
new tax on Wall Street speculation the
proposed
goes further than the plan previously
unveiled by his Democratic primary rival
senator Elizabeth Warren her debt relief
package would would was subject to
income eligibility levels to determine
how much relief the average person would
receive under the Sanders plan if you
have student debt of any kind it would
be canceled the second legislation is
signed into law so if you are you know a
rich doctor you're your debt is getting
cancelled just the same way that it
would if you were you know working at
McDonald's because the degree didn't
exactly do for you what you thought it
would do either way it's being treated
the same and this is the competition
that we're gonna see now between the
Socialists and the Democratic Party
which is basically all of them at this
point whether they're profess socialists
or not the competition is someone offers
free stuff than someone else says oh you
know what I'll see that and I'll give
you more free stuff and then the next
person but I'll give you even more free
stuff and that's gonna be there's gonna
be a debate we're gonna have two debates
this week Democratic debates I think on
NBC tomorrow night and Thursday and
that's really what the entire debate is
gonna be my my opponent says that he's
gonna give you free stuff but I actually
will give you that free stuff and also
more free stuff and that's gonna be the
whole the whole argument now if you
think he's actually going to pay for all
of this with a tax on Wall Street you
are stupid
no offense keep in mind that he wants to
forgive student debt and make College
free for everyone that's so there's one
point six trillion dollars of student
debt still outstanding in this country
Sanders wants to pay for that by taxing
Wall Street he says he's gonna raise 2.2
trillion dollars in ten years but then
he also wants to make College free for
everyone forever well that only leaves
six hundred billion dollars to make
College free for everyone forever and
it's gonna cost a hell of a lot more
than six hundred billion dollars not six
hundred billion dollars is a lot of
money but it's gonna cost a lot more
than that he can't just wave his wand
and make College free for everyone these
colleges
are staffed by people administrators
professors janitors coaches etc these
colleges have utility needs maintenance
needs many of them have huge stadiums to
maintain you got the dorms yeah I mean
it's just there are hundreds of expenses
thousands of expenses significant
expenses go into running a college
especially a really big College all of
those expenses are not going to be
erased right now I think it's probably
true that a lot of college
administrators especially get paid way
more than they should but unless you're
thinking of slave labor unless you're
going to force people to teach at
college and work out you got to pay them
where's that money gonna come from well
I'll give you the answer the money's
gonna come from you and me I totally
believe that wall street the the big bad
rich people like Bernie Sanders himself
who's a millionaire are going to carry a
large portion of the burden but they're
not gonna carry all of it they can't so
this is gonna fall on you and me don't
fall for this Wall Street's nonsense for
a second this money will come out of
your pocket and mine and there's no way
around it you know Alexandra occasi
Cortez made a good point about all this
yesterday unintentionally good I mean
the she made the good point was the
opposite of the point she was trying to
make but here she is yesterday talking
about free college watch this I think so
much about this moment when I was in
college and I was mentoring this girl
that this young woman her name was on
today as she was about three or four
years younger than me but I was about 19
years old and she was in high school and
she had gotten into all of these
prestigious universities but she was
given no student loan assistance no real
student she was given no scholarships
all of her student aid was presented to
her in the form of loans and she came
from a solid middle
laughs family she was not exceedingly
wealthy and and so she really she got
into her dream dream College but her
dream College offered her no
scholarships just loans and she truly
felt at sixteen seventeen years old
she felt that the decision of college
was so important that she felt that she
needed to consider taking on two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars worth of debt
okay so the girl wanted to go to her
dream college but she didn't get any
scholarships so she decided to take on
$250,000 of debt so she could go to her
dream college well why did she need to
take on that debt in order to go to
college see this isn't a sob story about
someone who couldn't go to any college
didn't have any money this is I think
Cortez X described her as solidly middle
class which means probably upper-middle
class and she wanted to go to her dream
college $250,000 there are many ways to
go to college that will not cost
anywhere close to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars you could go to a
community college for two years transfer
to a state school and you could do it
for much much much much less than 250
grand she took on that debt because she
wanted specifically to go to her dreams
school but here's the thing your dream
version of anything dream school dream
car dream house dream vacation is going
to be extremely expensive that's why
it's a dream most people never have
their dream anything most people go
their whole lives and they never have
their dream version of any particular
thing most people if they ever go on
their dream vacation they do it when
they're retired and they have less
expenses and they've saved up and that's
when they do their dream thing my dream
bottle of bourbon costs $2,000 on the
secondary market I'm probably not ever
going
to buy that bottle of bourbon I'm never
gonna spend $2,000 on a bottle of
bourbon so it remains a dream it's just
something that I can lay my head on my
pillow at night and fall asleep dreaming
of that of that bourbon that's that's
why again we call it a dream so for most
people in fact everyone here's the thing
we all have our dream thing right our
dream house dream vacation dream
whatever most anyone could have their
dream thing if they had the money for it
that's the situation we're all in but
most people what they do is they realize
they don't have the money for it and so
they don't buy that thing if you buy
your dream thing even though you didn't
have the money for it that's your fault
that's wasteful and honestly selfish and
that's on you
it's not on anybody else there are there
are worst
there are worse sob stories than the one
that Cortez shared with us people who
are crushed by hundreds of thousand
dollars of debt you know people who
people who are crushed by by debt or
maybe not hundreds of thousand you know
generally if you're crushed by hundreds
of thousands this isn't the case for
everyone but you know if you want to
become a doctor go to medical school
well that's gonna it's not about going
to your dream school it's just you want
to be a doctor we do need doctors and
you're gonna take on hundreds of
thousand dollars of debt and I agree
that's too much that's crazy so I do
feel for people in that position but
there are a lot of people that they want
to go to that really expensive college
not because they have any particular
career in mind but just because it's
prestigious maybe that's where their
rich friends are going they want to be
able to tell people they went there they
just want the experience of it I mean
that's why a lot of people spend that
kind of money on college and so that's a
sob story that
just really doesn't do it for me
here's here's here's the problem with
this student loan forgiveness stuff the
real victims are going to be the people
who made responsible choices that's
those are the real victims and we'll
talk about that in a moment but first I
want to tell you that today's podcast is
brought to you by VIN Cheryl watches no
matter what you consider your style to
be quality classic wristwatch is
something that I think every man needs
there are situations where you just need
that you need to class it up a bit and
you need that watch they're always going
to be occasions where you want to look
sharp you want to impress and just
wearing a computer on your wrist like an
Apple watch that's that's not going to
impress anyone we're partnering with VIN
share oh so you can get a truly stunning
watch at an even more impressive price
exclusively for our listeners of inch
arrows offering an extra 50% off their
exceptionally crafted watches goats even
chair watches comm forward slash Walsh
and use code Walsh to save an extra 15%
that's VI n C ero watches comm forward
slash Walsh Walsh and I can't even
pronounce my own name and code Walsh for
15% off this is our is our first time
working with the guys over at VIN chair
oh and they were nice enough to send me
one of their watches which I'm wearing
right now which I wear a lot of a lot
very proudly and I'm wearing the chrono
S matte gray I've been wearing it all
the time people are always complimenting
it pinch arrows strives to be the best
value in their industry and I believe
there are you're not gonna find better
made watches for this good of a price
anywhere else this is kind of this is it
this is where you got to go head the
Vinci Rose website right now and you're
gonna read all of the five stars over
fifteen thousand five star reviews which
prove the point as I said I'm wearing
the chrono s matte gray but the cheerio
has dozens of watches to choose from I
picked my top 5 which you can go to the
website and if you go to Finch arrow
watches comm forward slash Walsh you
could see my picks and you you can use
that code for 15% off these watches
already look way
more expensive than they are which means
when you use your 50% off you're getting
one hell of a deal go to VI n CER o
watches comm forward slash Walsh and
code walls for 15% off okay so the real
victims here the real victims of loan
forgiveness are the responsible people
people who made the sacrifices to
actually pay their back their loans
people who've spent you know a hundred
thousand dollars of the last twenty
years paying back those loans paying
them on time being responsible or people
like myself we didn't go to college at
all because we couldn't afford it and
instead we chose a different path in
life we made sacrifices and we struggled
and we made something of ourselves in
spite of that and to now just come in
and erase all of that debt and
especially to do it by using our money
well that is incredibly unjust and
immoral and I'll tell you something if
you're gonna do that
I want reparations okay I'm lining up
everyone's lining up for reparations I'm
lining up I want my reparations all
right as I said I didn't go to college
because I couldn't afford it I've been
paying off my wife's loans for the last
eight years okay me as the person who
doesn't have a college degree
I'm supporting a family of five paying
for a house paying for two cars paying
for my wife's loans as well
I want financial compensation for that I
want compensation for all of the money
that I've been spending on on my wife's
loans
I want compensation for that and I want
compensation because I Phi for foregoing
a college degree I couldn't afford it I
didn't go if I knew if it was free at
the time then maybe I would have went
and so I want compensation for that we
could talk about what the compensation
might be but but look from for as I've
told the story before from the ages of
about 20 to 27
I was extremely broke and and especially
from 20 to 25 and then 25 to 27 was a
little bit less broke but still pretty
broke I had to make a lot of sacrifices
during that time and it took me a long
time to get to the place where I am now
well
maybe if I'd gone to college cuz it was
free I wouldn't have been as broke
during those time so I want some of that
money the money that I could have made
had I gone to college had it been free
at the time or had I known that they
would just that I wouldn't have to pay
the loans because they would just
forgive them I want that money I want to
check is what I want that's you know
that's only fair right you can't erase
the debt of some 23 year olds who just
got out of college and paid almost
nothing towards it
while leaving those of us who have been
paying it off for a decade or more in
the lurch you just you can't do that
what we're out a ton a ton of money
right and and so what that we're just
out of luck too bad I'm fine with that
attitude don't get me wrong I know you
could say well too bad you know you
you're at a load you you it was your
responsibility you paid it back you made
choices and uh you know sorry that's
that's life um here's my that's my point
if that's your answer to me I agree
that's exactly yes agreed but then that
has to be the message to everybody not
just to me not just to the people who
who've put a hundred thousand dollars
back into their loans which is way more
than they ever took out over twenty
years you can't just say to them oh
you're out of luck hey that's life if
that's the message to them fine but it's
the message to everybody including the
23 year old who just got out of college
hasn't made any sacrifices yet hasn't
done anything that's the thing it's arts
hard for me to feel sorry for someone in
that position you haven't done anything
with your life yet you haven't made the
sacrifices that the rest of us have made
I feel a lot more sorry for the people
who have actually paid it back and are
out all that money and now you're gonna
turn around and say nevermind you didn't
have to pay a dime so you wasted all of
that know those you are if you do that
then you're creating real victims
because then those are people who's put
their own money into it think of all the
sacrifices they had to make think of how
different their life could have been
they're the victims now
and I'm not even thinking of myself I
vote it's only eight years we've been
we've been paying off the my wife's
loans I mean there have been people has
it over a dupe and put a lot but a lot
more money into it and made a lot more
sacrifice I'm thinking of them they're
going to be the victims and their real
victims because they didn't choose that
okay they didn't choose to be screwed
over by the government in Bernie Sanders
at the last minute who swoops in and
says never mind and not only that but
you wasted all that money now we're
gonna take more of your money to make
College free for everybody else
they're the victims if you took out a
loan and agreed and sign on the dotted
line you are not a victim you agree to
it now I agree though it's way too much
money it's ridiculous these colleges are
fleecing people the banks are fleecing
people I agree with all of that but it's
the reality remains you still sign on
the dotted line you didn't have to and
there are a lot of people out there who
it the reason why again there are
exceptions if you're a doctor or
something like that that's different but
there are a lot of people with with just
exorbitant debt who took on that debt
for no reason other than they just
thought it'd be cool to go to they
wanted to go to the nicest college so
they could simply say that they went to
the nicest college so they could brag
about the nice college they went to and
they could be in the party scene and
they could be you know have the best
version of anything it was just total
selfishness there are a lot of people in
that position we don't want to talk
about those people we want to pretend
they don't exist we have to cry tears
you know for for all of these people
with all well you know there are a lot
of people who just made selfish
ridiculous decisions they could have
gone you know the reality is you you
know but I keep saying it again with
some exceptions for a lot of people
there are tons of people where you you
really didn't need to go to college at
all and there are a lot of jobs you just
don't need it but then there's a whole
big category of jobs where okay you do
need the degree even if it's sort of an
artificial need where the where the
companies have sort of decided
arbitrarily that we want to see that you
have a degree even though you don't
need a degree in order to do the job
capably but there are a lot of jobs in
that category and the jobs in that
category it doesn't really matter where
you got the degree from you could have
gotten it from anywhere they just want
to see that you have the degree that's
all they care about so if you spent
three hundred thousand dollars on
college he uses it was a stupid decision
you didn't have to do it you could have
spent a lot less and now you're telling
me that that that decision on your part
it falls on everyone else's shoulders
when they're the ones who made the more
humble decision and made the sacrifice
and said you know what I don't need the
best version I don't need to be able to
brag about you made that decision and so
now it's everyone else's responsibility
no sorry
no definitely not especially when you
consider that most of the people with
that kind of college debt these are
upper these are upper middle class to
upper class people okay there aren't a
lot of pull some exceptions there aren't
a lot of poor people out there with two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars of
college debt is it there aren't many in
that category most of the people in that
category are well-off and come from
well-off families and and now they're
whining uh you know I'm sorry I just it
especially when you've when you've lived
life for a while you know you just you
see that this is this is just life I
mean we all go through it and now you
want me to cry for you uh you know know
like I'm sorry I can't I I could be
sympathetic if you were dealing with
your financial struggles with dignity
and not demanding that the government
bail you out and not trying to steal
money from other people through the
government in order to solve your
problems if you weren't doing that and
you were just
dealing with the problem and struggling
silently with dignity then I have a
Thomas Titus sympathy I have ton of
sympathy for people in that position but
it's when you when you try to steal when
you ask Big Daddy government to bail you
out my sympathy just drains at that
point it's gone it evaporates alright
let's look at this so this woman who
accused Trump of rape eg Carol aren't
explained yesterday why I doubt her
story I think the story is literally
unbelievable and I think she's just not
a credible person or she doesn't seem
credible anyway for a number of reasons
one of those reasons that is that she
appears to be disturbed and I mean that
sincerely it's not an insult or anything
I don't mean it as a joke I mean I think
this woman has something wrong with her
mentally and to prove my point watch
this victim you don't feel like a victim
I was not throwing on the ground and
ravish which the word rape carries so
many sexual connotations this was not
this was not sexual for just it hurt it
just what it just you know I think most
people think of rape as a I mean it is a
violent assault it is not I think most
people think of rapists being sexy let's
take a short break of the fantasies
we've gotta take a quick break if you
can stick around we'll talk more on the
other side you're fascinating to talk to
no additional commentary needed there
the this woman is just not right in the
head that that that's what what else can
what can you say about that you yeah
that's that's draw your own conclusions
just you know watch that clip again and
ask yourself if this
a woman whose word you can trust all
right one other thing before we get to
some emails this is reading now from Fox
News Adam Silver the NBA commissioner
said in an interview published Monday
that the league has moved away from the
term owner and said they are now
referred to as governor's silver was
stopped in New York by TMZ said he is
sensitive to the term owner TMZ reported
earlier that few NBA teams have dropped
the term because of its racial component
and since most of the players in the
league are black so okay so there they
want to get rid of the term owner
because most of the players are black
and it supposedly brings to mind slavery
even though these men in the NBA are
paid millions of dollars and are adored
by legions of fans and live just an
amazing life so that that to me hasn't
is not similar to slavery that's not
what I think of slavery I think of the
exact opposite of NBA players basically
just the what I think of slavery I think
NBA players but the exact opposite
someone who is in the exact opposite
position in in pretty much every
conceivable way
so but that's what they're saying it's
it brings to mind slavery and even
though we're paid millions of dollars
and so now we're gonna use governor
instead that first of all it doesn't
that seem much weirder and creepier to
call them governors if the owner of a
company let's say you work for a company
because companies have owners to most
companies have owners if you came in to
work and the owner of your company
showed up and demanded that everyone
call him governor instead of owner
wouldn't that creep you out when that
strike you as deeply weird and and
troubling what have you went into a
store and you saw a guy who looked to be
in charge and you went up to him you
said I sir are you the owner oh no no no
call me governor what why we yeah just
call me governor I'm the governor of
these yeah but you're not you're not the
governor at all you're the owner of the
company its that would be weird because
it's it's
that is a classic example of taking a
problem that is not a problem and
solving it by creating a problem so
calling someone an owner when they do in
fact own the thing which is the team the
team that's not a problem now you're
calling them governor just just which is
so much worse what about the fact that I
own my house is that can I say that
still is that racially insensitive can I
call myself the owner of my house and
wait a second
remember the psycho dude from The
Walking Dead who had the eyepatch and it
wasn't he called the governor that's all
I can think of when I when I think it
when I hear the term I think of the
psycho dude with the eyepatch from from
the walking dead
that's governor this is this is beyond
parody all right let's go to emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Jack says hi Matt
I enjoy your show you've recently got
into reviewing songs on your show it
seems you have a particular distaste for
country rap songs you hated Old Town
Road you're wrong about that by the way
but what do you think of the song get up
can you at least acknowledge that it's
catchy well okay so I I hadn't heard of
the song which is not called it's called
the get up by the way not get up GI t
get get up that's what it's called
I hadn't heard of the song somehow I
escaped my notice before you mentioned
but I went back and looked it up it's a
it's by a guy named Blanco Brown so now
this country rap country trap I think
they call it is a whole genre now
growing genre old town road is a
terrible song but let's play a bit of
this one so that everyone knows we're
talking about here's here's the get up
by Blanco Brown I want to do that system
then cowboy driver sweetheart it's being
out when beautiful
[Music]
to the right to the ride now take your
lip and put it on your side okay you
know what that's that's catchy I can't
deny it that is uh that's a catchy damn
song so see to me that's catchy that's
fun that's gonna be a staple in every
wedding DJs playlist for the next 600
years so I appreciate that Old Town Road
is garbage there's nothing fun about it
it's not really catchy it's just there's
nothing going it's got no charm or
anything it's simply a bad song whereas
this is you know it's a it's kind of
dumb right but it's uh it's a fun so
it's a dance song and so yeah I can
appreciate that oh I will give that a
solid b-minus and I really don't give
out a pluses so that's pretty good I
mean that's so good that it almost makes
me want to dance
unfortunately when I dance I look like a
praying mantis having a seizure so I
won't but it does oh i'll remain seated
but in my head i'm dancing when i hear
that song so alright from luke says hi
matt what is the most annoying thing
people do while driving well do you have
five hours because there are so many
things everything is annoying in life
but especially when you're driving
especially for me because I am the only
good driver in the world I don't know if
you knew this I don't know if you
realize you're watching a show hosted by
officially the only good driver in the
world and so I sit in judgment of all
other drivers I judge you if you're
whoever you are watching this your worst
right I judge you you're not good I'm a
good driver you're not no one is a good
driver but me and I come from a long
line of men who are the only good
drivers my dad
always claimed to be the only good job
he still says he's the only good driver
but he can't be because I am so I've
unseated him in that position so there
are so many things that people do wrong
while I Drive let's start with the with
the fact that they're on the road in the
first place when they're bad drivers the
road what I I expect that when I get out
on the highway I'm I'm gonna have the
highway to myself because I'm the only
one who's capable of doing it as I have
discovered I'm clearly the only one who
knows how to do this so the rest of you
should stay home ride a bike
or something you could dig holes you
know maybe dig Oh an elaborate series of
tunnels like you could be like moles or
something going from place to place how
about that just stay out of the way so
that I can drive I know what I'm doing
what's the main thing people do wrong
well it's hard to even point out it kind
of like it depends on what are we on a
highway are we on a back road or we go
in suburbia but we on a roll you know a
neighborhood are we in a parking lot I
mean if we're on a highway I'll tell you
the main thing people do wrong is
merging and what people do is they get
scared I guess and they slam on their
brakes when they're trying to merge
treating it like a stop sign or they
slow way way down and that's not what
you're supposed to do when you merge
you're supposed to speed up you want to
get with the speed of traffic and if you
slow down too much and then you try to
merge what's gonna happen is that all of
the people are that they all now they
have to slam on their brakes because
this you know this this slowpoke just
dropped himself into the middle of the
highway if everyone's going 70 miles an
hour and you merge going 30 you're going
to kill people speed up to merge if you
don't know how to do this then stay
that's all I'm saying if you don't know
how to do it then stay home that dies
it's real simple they need to put this
stuff on the driving test that's what
they I mean the driving what I don't
know how the driving test works now I
guess but here's how it and tell me if
it's changed the way it works for me is
we went around in a circle a couple of
times we went we run around like a few
cones and then we
parallel parked and for me when I for
the driving test the parallel parking
was the star attraction was the main
thing it's the main way people failed
their test how stupid is that you could
go your hook now it's true that most
people don't know how to parallel park
and that's a problem and again I'm the
best parallel Parker but I can do it in
three turns no problem but you could go
your whole life and never parallel park
you can avoid parallel parking if you're
bad at it it's even if you live in the
city you could probably get away with
avoiding it well maybe not in that case
but most people can get it can go their
whole life and never parallel park but
or at least not have to parallel park in
a really tight space you know a lot of
people can avoid that merging onto the
highway though that's something that you
do most a lot of people do every day
multiple times a day so why doesn't the
driving test involve stuff like that
things that actually are a crucial part
of everyday driving and things that by
the way if you do wrong you could kill
someone if you parallel park wrong
you're just gonna bump someone's fender
but if you do these other things wrong
someone could die and so that's why that
stuff should be on the driving test
although again everybody in the world
should fail their driving tests except
for me
alright this is from let's see this is
from Sarah says I I was never a mother
myself but I've been watching a step
grandchild quite often she's five months
old now and I feel guilty when her only
issue clearly is exhaustion and she
won't fall asleep is it okay to let her
cry it out I feel like someone was
raised multiples can answer this
question better than most god bless you
a lot of interesting questions today I'm
like a lot of random questions that have
nothing to do with anything and I say
that as a I appreciate that by the way I
mean that yeah crying it out you know I
I think a problem with parenting these
days is that first of all
is controversial everything you do is
apparent there's gonna be someone who
says it's abusive and terrible you're an
awful parent so the you know you know
whatever you do you'll be judged for it
and we're always like coming up with
labels and terms and strategies and
things where are you were this kind of
parent or that kind of parent do you cry
it out or not cut cry it out we call it
the cry it out method it's it's not a
method it's a it's not a it's not a type
of parenting it's it's nothing special
it's a very simple thing which is if you
put a baby down to bed and he starts
crying well you're gonna go check on the
baby make sure that everything's okay
that he's safe and I mean doesn't need
to be changed does he is he hungry you
know you'll make sure that all his needs
are met that he's safe that everything's
fine but if he keeps crying which
sometimes babies will do even though all
their needs are met everything's fine
they're just they're crying because
they're tired babies will cry when
they're tired and then because babies
are babies they don't understand that
when you cry now you're just keeping
yourself awake you're exacerbating the
problem so just stop crying and then you
could fall asleep and in that situation
then yeah I think you just maybe you
just let the baby alone for a few
minutes let it let the baby cry and
he'll usually pass out and go to sleep
in a few minutes
that's the cried out method it boggles
my mind that there are people so my
answer to you Sarah is I see nothing
wrong with it there are people out there
say oh you could never do that never let
him what so you never let the baby cried
his crib ever what so every time he
cries even if all his needs but you just
go and get him up every time you know
you won't even let him cry for 20
seconds that's crazy to me I mean how
could you function as a human being that
way and if you do that your babies never
gonna learn to sleep there are a lot
I'll tell you something we've had we've
had three kids so far we got fourth on
the way we did do multiples we had twins
we had we had we get two infants at one
time so we've been through it and with
all of our kids and it's only three so
far but they've all been pretty good
papers and they all sleep through the
night and just in like we get them to
the point where they're sleeping through
the night in a few months and you hear
from these parents that you know their
kids are like one and a half two years
old they're still not so they're still
waking up in the middle of the night
they don't sleep they don't sleep we
don't have that problem and I think one
of the reasons is that this is that this
is the method we use which is kids
crying we meet we meet their needs if
their needs are met and they're safe we
let them cry not for six hours but but
just for a little bit until they fall
asleep and usually they will and they
learn to sleep and and so we have kids
who sleep it's amazing it's great well
why I think a lot of parents they they
cause they end up with kids who never
learn how to sleep because you never
give him a chance
so yes I I am an advocate for the cried
out method and I know that by saying
that I have just invited hundreds of
emails from people horrified you let
your child cry how could you do that I'd
never let my child cry for one minute no
no's it was okay he'll be traumatized
your child will remember when your child
is thirty years old he'll remember the
time when he was two months old and
crying and you never came he'll be in
therapy talking about it
you monster those are the emails I'm
gonna get all right so I can't read
anymore every email I've read so far has
just set me off on a deranged rant so I
think I need to stop reading them before
I have a heart attack
live on camera which would be
interesting and probably would get a lot
of views maybe I should consider that
but not today so we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody
Godspeed Bernie Sanders proposes that
tax payers pay off every single student
loan in the country we will explain how
student loan forgiveness is welfare for
the rich then the woman accusing
president Trump of rape describes rape
as sexy finally the United States might
go to war with Iran
we'll explain it all on the Michael
Noel's show